all right so we saw this Japanese  youtuber tacky you gain and attach a  ball to the end of a string let's try it  out  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  the good thing was this you don't have  to pick up the balls zerah zerah  [Music]  yes  [Music]  who  [Music]  [Music]  tough battle I think you're going for  the head shot  [Applause]  [Music]  I'll make sure to subscribe if you  haven't done it already let's go for the  two million  Stuart back at image Thank You training  [Applause]  [Applause]  foster for the server just kidding get  it in time anymore  [Applause]  try not to blink we should go and scare  people like hey okay so this was quite  fun and it worked surprisingly well and  don't forget to subscribe here and  what's our previous episodes there until  next time